[Musica]
spesso quando mi trovo davanti a una
platea noto che di solito l'argomento
sesso genera due tipi di reazioni
opposte e complementari
c'è chi già sorride il con un certo
compiacimento e raddrizza la schiena e
c'è chi invece si rannicchia sulla
poltrona con un po di disagio
bene se dovessi scegliere una metafora
spaziale per definire la relazione che
abbiamo in genere con la sessualità
userei quella della fortezza un luogo
chiuso dove custodire tante cose
preziose che vogliamo difendere un luogo
in cui anche nascondiamo dei segreti
bene rassicuratevi io oggi non vengo qui
ad assaltare la vostra fortezza potete
stare comodi e comode quello che voglio
fare con questo piccolo intervento a
mostrarvi un paio di spunti di critica è
un input creativo non vengo qui neo
giudicarvi né a dirvi che cosa è giusto
o sbagliato perché in realtà qualsiasi
modalità che hanno le persone di vivere
il sesso che sia consensuale e che non
arrechi danni fisici è comunque
legittima e non sono soltanto io a dirlo
che è notoriamente sono di mentalità
aperta
lo dice anche il dsm 5 che è la
pubblicazione periodica
dell'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità che definisce che cosa è malattia
mentale e che cosa non
nell'ambito della sessualità e che
appunto nella sua ultima edizione ad e
patologizzare quelle parafilie che un
tempo venivano definite perversioni e
che erano considerate malattie mentali
eppure l'idea che il sesso sia qualcosa
di naturale e che ci siano delle
pratiche che sono naturali e altre che
non lo sono
continua ad essere vigente è un concetto
che è molto caro a soprattutto a persone
organizzazioni e istituzioni che sulla
sessualità vorrebbero avere il controllo
in realtà la sessualità è una tecnologia
che si è evoluta nel corso dei secoli e
sull'idea che la libertà sessuale sia un
progresso a cui non dobbiamo rinunciare
penso che non dovremmo accettare nessun
tipo di relativismo perché la libertà
sessuale è costata molto spesso la vita
a molti uomini e donne che hanno pagato
caro la loro non aderenza al regime
sessuale dell'epoca in cui vivevano
e se parlo di regime e vi sembra
esagerato lasciatemi andare avanti la
nostra cultura sessuale occidentale anzi
diciamo proprio che la nostra cultura
occidentale è impregnata di immagini e
di storie in cui il sesso è un elemento
fondante
ma che tipo di sesso se pensiamo alla
mitologia greco romana
non possiamo non notare uno stillicidio
di violenze di stupri di atti sessuali
che quando non sono apertamente
traumatici sono comunque drammaticamente
non consensuali
pensiamo al rea silvia la madre di
romolo e remo mitici fondatori
nella città di roma rea silvia si
addormenta sulle rive del tevere il dio
marte la vede e decide di possederla lo
fa con delicatezza e silenziosamente e
lei nemmeno se ne accorge ne pagherà
soltanto le conseguenze ovviamente e
come non ricordare il gruppo marmoreo di
canova di apollo e dafne ti trovi lì
davanti e sei ancora abbagliata dalla
bianchezza del marmo e la guida ti
spinge a notare la plasticità dell'opera
questo movimento verso l'alto che
trasforma le morbide carne della ninfa
il ramo duro e foglie non ti racconta
l'urlo di dolore di daphne che dice
piuttosto che farmi toccare date di
vento di legno però purtroppo è una
situazione che forse ti capiterà di
provare più avanti nella vita e che dire
del ratto delle sabine un'altra storia
esemplare
gli abitanti della città di roma
originaria
erano tutti maschi nessuno li voleva
sposare e allora così simpaticamente
scelgono di tendere una trappola ha una
popolazione vicina organizzano una
grandissima festa con dei giochi
e mentre tutti quanti e sono ancora
felici e ubriachi rubano le donne è una
storia che ha un lieto fine
legato alla pazienza e alla saggezza
delle donne però una storia di cui dopo
molti secoli non abbiamo ancora imparato
la lezione
perché si continua a riprodurre in
maniera più o meno orribile
in realtà
il nostro immaginario sessuale è pieno
di storie in cui il sesso e violenza e e
questa fortezza che noi difendiamo tanto
gelosamente contiene anche queste storie
e parliamo di immaginario sessuale
non parliamo di educazione sessuale che
quello è anche un altro baratro in cui
per oggi non guarderemo rispetto
all'immaginario sessuale o un'esperienza
personale che va avanti da va da anni in
cui mi confronto con un sacco di persone
sul tema della pornografia sono uomini e
donne che sono cresciute nell'era pre
internet
beh la gran parte di loro hanno avuto il
primo contatto con la pornografia ben
prima dei 10 anni e quindi che succede
che il nostro immaginario sessuale è
stato influenzato con forme di
pornografia dirette e indirette oltre
che con questi archetipi così violenti e
e tutto questo continua estere nella
nostra fortezza e quindi il mio invito
per oggi è quello se non di abbassare
proprio il ponte levatoio di lasciare
entrare un po di aria fresca dentro la
nostra fortezza aprire uno spiraglio per
che potremmo fare da una parte delle
belle scoperte ridiscutendo tutte quelle
convinzioni che custodiamo gelosamente
su quello che ci eccita e quello che non
ci eccita su quali sono i nostri
standard di bellezza e quali sono le
negazioni assolute e forse riusciremo
anche a fare pace con tutta una serie di
insoddisfazioni e di frustrazioni che ci
portiamo avanti da un sacco di anni e
non sappiamo da dove vengo
molte molti comportamenti disfunzionali
nell'ambito della sessualità sono molto
spesso legati più a delle sofferenze
sociali e culturali che ha delle
patologie per e proprie ecco questo è il
mio invito per oggi e e mi augurerei che
un giorno tutte queste nostre fortezze
si possano trasformare in giardini che
possiamo ripulire dalle erbacce in cui
possiamo coltivare tutti i fiori che più
ci piacciono anche i cactus e in cui
magari possiamo invitare gli amici e le
amiche a prendere un tè
[Applauso]